الجديد بان هناك حقيقه الامر المباني
مناطق جديده لم تكن يعني يعني يعتقد البعض
بانه يوجد فيها انهيارات هناك انهيارات
شوارع باكملها مباني على رؤوس ساكنينها
بان هناك ما لا يقل عن 58 بلده وقريه
ومدينه بشكل قطعي يوجد فيها انهيار
للمباني الجديد بان عدد ضحايا يتصاعد بشكل
مستمر نتيجه انقاذ او اخراج حقيقه الامر
بعض الوفيات من تحت الانقاد ولكن دعني
اقول لك بان هناك الكثير من المباني
المتهمه على رؤوس ساكنيها او قاتليها لا
يوجد فرق انقاص كي تقوم باخراج هؤلاء يعني
الذين لا يزالون على قيد الحياه من تحت
انقاذ هذه المباني او حتى الوفيات التحت
هذه المباني اي انها عدد الخسائر البشريه
قد يصل الى 200 شخص ان لم نقل اكثر بكثير
نتيجه وجود يعني عدد الوفيات والمصابين
بشكل قطعي هو المئات لم نقل يعني قد يرتفع
ولكن رامي رامي نريد تاكيد هذه الارقام
السلطات التركيه السلطات التركيه هنا
نتحدث تحدثت عن 76 قتيل في المناطق
التركيه وهي مناطق ربما مؤهله اكثر
لحضاريا فيما يتعلق بعدم وجود حروب بوجود
قوات او السلطات تركيا قادره على انقاذ
المزيد من المحاصرين تحت الانقاذ لماذا
يرتفع الرقم في تركيا الى 200 قتيل وهل
نستطيع القول بان هذه الارقام الاوليه
ولكن مؤكده
غير يعني ارقام اوليه يعني نتحدث نحن على
العدد الذين تحدثنا ما بين المناطق النظام
وما بين مناطق ادلب ومناطق السيطره
التركيه نتحدث عن ما لا يقل عن 150 خطيره
وفيه على الاقل حتى اللحظه المؤكده العدد
اكبر من ذلك بكثير لا يوجد امكانيه لاحصاء
كافه النقاط الطبيه والمشافي في الوقت
الراهن